[Music]
in such an insane and journey and I mean
Ryan is the best human ever a truly like
I I really hope every actor gets to work
with him because it's just like working
with a friend he's just the best
Ryan Johnson is doing another trilogy
and I have not even seen the last Jedi
yet so you know more than that I do
about Ryan in Star Wars why do you think
that he's the perfect person to take on
a new trilogy that's like a completely
blank slate I think that Ryan isn't
afraid to do something that's different
and I think that's really hard with
something that has been established and
something that people love so much I am
that movie really feels like it's a
standalone film if that makes any sense
there are great action sequences there
are great characters but every single
character has an arc every character has
some sort of a mental physical or
emotional challenge that they're going
through and it's pretty incredible to
kind of see what he's done with it I
think that he there is not a more
perfect person to make something new in
that universe and I can't wait to see
that new trilogy
[Music]
you